VERSUS TRUMP TREATS, THAT'S THE
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
DEMOCRATS ARE PUTTING ALL OF
THEIR CANDY IN A NEW BASKET OF
CANDIDATES THIS HALLOWEEN AND
THE RESULT FOR AMERICANS CAN BE
DOWNRIGHT NAUSEATING.
HERE IS DEMOCRATIC GUBERNATORIAL
HOPEFUL ANDREW GILLUM ON THE
TRICK HE HAS IN STORE FOR
FLORIDA VOTERS.
>> RAISE TAXES ON BUSINESSES.
I BELIEVE BUSINESSES ARE TO PAY
THEIR FAIR SHARE.
>> YOU WANT MEDICARE FOR ALL FOR
ALL.
>> IT OUT TO BE A RIGHT NOT A
PRIVILEGE.
>> SO YOU WOULD ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
YOU ARE PERHAPS MORE AGGRESSIVE.
>> I WOULDN'T DENY ANY DAY OF
THE WEEK.
>> Laura: EVERYTHING IS FREE,
NO ONE HAS TO PAY ANYTHING.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THIS IS WHAT
FLORIDA VOTERS REALLY WANT.
HIGHER TAXES, MORE SPENDING,
MORE REGULATIONS THAT WILL END
UP CHOKING THEIR STATES THRIVING
ECONOMY.
AND THERE'S ANOTHER CHARISMATIC
LEFTIST RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR OF
GEORGIA, SHE HAS A SPOOKY VIEW
OF BASIC ECONOMICS.
>> I'M SICK AND TIRED OF HEARING
ABOUT THE FREE MARKET BEING THE
SOLUTION TO OUR PROBLEMS.
>> Laura: WHY WASTE TIME WITH
CAPITALISM WHEN SOCIALIST
REDISTRIBUTION SEEMS SO MUCH
MORE FAIR?
ABRAMS IS CURRENTLY RUNNING NECK
AND NECK WITH REPUBLICAN
SECRETARY OF STATE BRIAN KEMP
AND NOW SHE'S TRYING TO CONNECT
WITH REGULAR FOLKS BY BRINGING
IN STAR POWER.
OPRAH IS COMING INTO TOWN AND
SHE'S HOPING TO BE THE QUEEN
MAKER IN GEORGIA, AND COMEDIAN
WILL FERRELL IS GOING DOOR TO
DOOR TO CANVAS FOR ABRAMS HOPING
THAT YOU THINK HE'S A REAL
ANCHORMAN WHO KNOWS SOMETHING
ABOUT POLITICS.
FORMER PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA
AND SENATOR BERNIE SANDERS ARE
ALSO EXPECTED IN GEORGIA NEXT
WEEK, MEANWHILE
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA HEADED
DOWN TO FLORIDA ON FRIDAY --
TOTALLY UNFAZED BY THE NEW
REVELATIONS THAT HIS GUY ANDREW
GILLUM WAS AGAIN SHOWN TO BE
CORRUPT.
WHAT HE DID?
HE USED TAXPAYER FUNDS FROM HIS
MAYORAL OFFICE TO TAKE A PRIVATE
PLANE TO MEET WITH HIS DONORS TO
HIS GUBERNATORIAL RUN.
WHEN CONFRONTED ON HIS
CORRUPTION, GILLUM RUNS TO RACE.
>> I DON'T TAKE FREE TRIPS FOR
ANYBODY, I'M A HARDWORKING
PERSON -- I KNOW THAT MAY NOT
FIT YOUR DESCRIPTION BUT I DON'T
NEED ANY ONE HANDING ANYTHING
FOR FREE.
>> Laura: THAT SUBJECT ISN'T
TOO HARD TO READ.
A FREQUENT TRICK IS USED TO DO
FLEX QUESTIONS BY CLAIMING HIS
OPPONENTS REPUBLICAN BOB
DeSANTIS IS A BLATANT RACIST.
>> I DO THINK THAT
MR. DeSANTIS IS GIVEN TOO MUCH
HARBOR TO RACISTS AND A
XENOPHOBE'S AND ANTI-SEMITES, HE
SPOKEN AT CONFERENCES WITH THEM,
HE AUTHORED A BOOK JUSTIFYING
SLAVERY.
>> Laura: THAT IS JUST A
BALD-FACED LIE.
RON DeSANTIS WROTE A BOOK
JUSTIFYING SLAVERY?
IT'S A WONDER HE WAS EVER
ELECTED TO THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
WE PULLED TO THE BOOK, IT'S
CALLED DREAMS FROM OUR FOUNDING
FATHERS AND IN IT, DeSANTIS
RECOUNTS HOW ALEXANDER HAMILTON
AND BENJAMIN FRANKLIN LAMENTED
THE "NOTORIOUS COMPROMISES" THAT
WERE MADE TO TOLERATE SLAVERY SO
THE CONSTITUTION COULD ACTUALLY
PASS, THEY COULD FORM A
GOVERNMENT.
HERE'S A QUOTATION.
THE RECITATION OF HISTORICAL
FACT IS NOT RACIST, NOR IS IT
JUSTIFYING SLAVERY.
EITHER ANDREW GILLUM IS REALLY
NOT ALL THAT SMART, OR HE'S
PURPOSEFULLY LYING ABOUT
SOMETHING THIS AWFUL AND
HORRIBLE.
IT'S DEFAMATORY AND SHOULD NOT
BE TOLERATED OR REWARDED BY THE
VOTERS OF FLORIDA.
RACISM SEEMS TO BE ONE OF THE
MOST POTENT FORCES THAT THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE IN THEIR TRICK
BAG THIS MIDTERM SEASON.
EVERYWHERE YOU TURN, THE REFRAIN
IS THE SAME.
>> WHAT I DID WRONG IN 2016 WAS
I OVERESTIMATED WHITE PEOPLE.
I DIDN'T THINK WHITE PEOPLE
WOULD PUT HIM IN OFFICE.
SO HERE HE IS RUNNING AROUND THE
COUNTRY, APPEALING TO OUR DARKER
ANGELS, APPEALING TO OUR HATRED
AND FEAR.
AND I'M SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE THAT
OHIO ISN'T GOING TO VOTE FOR
HIM?
THAT THE SUBURBS IN PENNSYLVANIA
AREN'T GOING TO VOTE FOR HIM?
SPEAK OF EVIDENCE IS THERE, I
HAVE TO GIVE THE FACTS AND THE
TRUTH.
THE TRUTH AND THE EVIDENCE
POINTS TO HIM BEING A RACIST.
HE IS A RACIST.
>> Laura: THIS IS RACE BAITING
TAKEN TO A NEW LOW, IF IT'S EVEN
POSSIBLE TO GO ANY LOWER.
RATHER THAN MOUNT CREDIBLE
ARGUMENTS IN THE FACE OF
TRUMP'S, IT'S EASIER TO TAR HIM
AND ALL REPUBLICANS WERE EVER
SUPPORTED HIM AS RACISTS OR
MEMBERS OF THE THIRD REICH, THEY
ARE RACE OBSESSED ON THE LEFT.
APPEARS.
HERE'S INDIANA'S DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR JOE DONNELLY WHO
RECENTLY ATTEMPTED TO BRAG ABOUT
SOME OF HIS EMPLOYEES, OR AT
LEAST ABOUT THEIR ETHNICITY.
>> OUR STATE DIRECTOR IS INDIAN
AMERICAN.
HE DOES AN AMAZING JOB.
OUR DIRECTOR OF ALL CONSTITUENT
SERVICES, SHE'S AFRICAN-AMERICA
AFRICAN-AMERICAN.
SHE DOES A MORE INCREDIBLE JOB
AND YOU CAN EVER IMAGINE.
>> Laura: I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THAT IS.
AT A MOMENT WHEN THE COUNTRY IS
FOCUSED ON IMMIGRATION AND
SECURING THE BORDER, TEXAS
DEMOCRATIC SUPERSTAR BETO
O'ROURKE DROPPED THIS TREAT ON
MSNBC'S CHRIS MATTHEWS.
HE SLIPPED IT IN HIS VIEW OF THE
BORDER WHEN TALKING ABOUT HOW HE
MET HIS WIFE.
>> WE MET ON A BLIND DATE IN
EL PASO BEFORE TINDER, I TOOK
HER OVER THE BRIDGE, HAD A
MARGARITA AT THE KENTUCKY CLUB,
WE JUST HIT IT OFF.
I TOLD THAT STORY TO FOLKS TO
REMIND THEM OF THE BINATIONAL
NATURE OF THE U.S.-MEXICO BORDE
BORDER.
>> Laura: SOMEHOW, SOMEWHERE
THAT PASSES AS REALLY
INTELLIGENT, THE BINATIONAL
NATURE OF THE BORDER.
A BORDER IS BETWEEN TURTLE
COUNTRIES.
THERE ARE TWO BUT WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN, BINATIONAL NATURE?
THERE ARE TWO DISTINCT NATIONS
AND A BORDER SHOULD BE PROTECTE
PROTECTED.
NOW COMPARE ALL OF THOSE
DEMOCRATIC TRICKS, THE EMPTY
RACISM CHARGES, A VISION OF AN
OPEN BORDER, ABOLISHING ICE, ALL
OF THAT STUFF TO TRUMPS TREATS.
NOW UNDER THIS PRESIDENT, WAGES
AND SALARIES ROSE 3.1% IN THE
THIRD QUARTER, THE BIGGEST
INCREASE IN A DECADE.
GDP EXPANDED BY 3.5% ANNUAL RACE
AHEAD OF THE 3.4% EXPECTATION.
AFRICAN-AMERICAN AND HISPANIC
UNEMPLOYMENT ARE AT HISTORIC
LOWS, AND THE PRESIDENT IS
TAKING REAL STEPS LIKE SENDING
5,000 TROOPS TO THE BORDER TO
PROTECT OUR SOVEREIGNTY.
YOUR BOTTOM LINE, YOUR WALLET.
YOU KNOW THE DEMOCRATS DON'T
OFFER ANY COGENT ARGUMENT OR
RESPONSE, ALTERNATIVE TO THE
TRUMP RECORD.
THEY EXPECT TO WIN VIA A
SUSTAINED CAMPAIGN OF ANTI-TRUMP
ANGER AND RACE BAITING.
LIKE OLD HALLOWEEN CANDY, NONE
OF THAT IS GOING TO SATISFY OR
SUSTAIN THE COUNTRY.